um
okay
let's try eric from cancun now eric
happy new year i want to i want you to
get right into your question because you
know we've struggled with that in the
past my friend go right into it what's
your question today
hi david i will read you something i
wrote in reddit
it says i know if republicans can be
trusted in the part of maturity
if other than not they
didn't use cartoons as real world
examples also picking fights with
cartoon characters that might be because
republicans can either be envious or
intimidated that sesame street and have
higher moral levels than them let's not
forget that margery taylor green went to
portray the green new deal as a
scooby-doo monster and when fred was on
asking the monster the culprit was
communist and the incident of attack on
titan do you remember
wow eric i have no idea what you're
talking about did you just read
something or is that something you wrote
it's something i wrote in your discord
it's about republicans wanting to use
cartoons as real
examples for politics
you remember when marjorie taylor green
went to portray the green new deal as a
scooby-doo monster i don't remember that
i don't remember that no
and they were using memes in the
in the senate floor
i remember memes on the senate floor yes
that i remember
yeah soon
and they were in picking fights with dr
seuss and sesame street yes i remember
that
um
and i can i don't think they would be
mature enough to
focus in real politics is there using
cartoons as real world examples
i mean
some that would be the job of
politicians and actual cartoonists and
not in those whom we trust with the laws
that's an incredibly astute observation
eric eric how is the weather in cancun
now it's sunny it's a bit cold but i
like it in winter and
awesome
and
who do you think they would go after
next like disney or cartoon network
because he belonged to ted turner and he
made captain planet or my little pony
i'm not sure eric eric from cancun
always uh unblemished every phone call
is absolutely perfect i really
appreciate
uh hearing hearing from you
um wow that is really really something
else
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video